sorry to make you pick one of your
children but uh what's the weirdest one
would you say
the weirdest body part um or concept
or function
so the chapters you divide it up kind of
into parts
but
there could be a thread that connects
all them the weirdness
maybe
or maybe the the texture of the
substance could be the liquids the
solids i don't know
definitely every body part and bodily
fluid has their own um kind of both
gross and fascinating aspects that's
probably why i'm a generalist as a
doctor and couldn't just as you said
pick one of my children become a
specialist because i like them all
i feel like one of the strangest
concepts about the human body is that
kind of the aspects of it that are the
most universal that we all do are the
most taboo socially
um i wouldn't have expected that if i
had you know just looked from the
outside like what we do in the bathroom
what we do in the bedroom what we do to
our
own genitals what we do to our uh you
know
quote-unquote private parts they're
private even though it's sort of the
thing that we have all have in common
um is the most we try to hide from other
people and don't talk about polite
company i mean it makes sense as a human
living in the society but from the
outside it sort of might be surprising
how do you make sense of that if you put
on your
sigmund freud hat the thing we all do
why do we make that
a taboo thing is it because we like
taboos maybe we get off or maybe our our
our our kinks as humans is to have
taboos and it's kind of efficient to
have taboos about the things that
everybody does
like you can make walking taboo
or something i don't know but just uh
maybe that's what we love that's what's
exciting to us is the is the forbidden
i think yes society loves rules for sure
they loves
some societies more than others you know
they love controlling how you think and
what you do in public versus private you
know there's a lot of societies where
for instance parents have sex in front
of children
um not you know for instance like in in
a traditional inupiat eskimo societies
that was sort of normal
i mean but what are you gonna do go
outside in the middle of the winter in
the arctic and do it out there of course
not so um you know there's different uh
different taboos in different societies
some taboos make perfect sense some
taboos are
even public health measures you know
like as i talk in the book about in in
india where they
uh you know the hands are symmetric as
you said but in indian culture and the
left hand is taboo and the right hand is
what you use for shaking hands for
eating for other things and the left
hand is
the dirty hand that you use for wiping
your own bottom you know that's the
toilet paper is your left hand so
um while the body is anatomically
symmetric the taboo creates this pretty
intense asymmetry
uh but for a good reason you know you
probably shouldn't be shaking hands with
other people with the same hand that you
use to kind of clean your bottom so in
that sense it makes sense
yeah maybe the roots of it make sense
but the way it propagates especially as
the times change might not because you
can wash your hands
uh but the the taboo remains right
society is very slow to change
you